hello i hope that everyone is safe and
well
my name is buzz lobzu and i'm the
product support and development manager
at australia bioseparations limited
formerly known as
prometics by separations limited i've
been with the company
for nearly 16 years and in that time
i've performed downstream processing
troubleshooting and working with our
products and customers alike
in this presentation i want to talk to
you about the turnkey approach that
australia offers
in develop delivering gmp ready
absorbents and columns
starting from initial ligand discovery
thereby supporting
our customers and fulfilling their unmet
unmet needs
one of the biggest challenges the
biotech and bio therapeutic companies
are facing
is the development of processes that
deliver safe
cost-effective and efficient products
the main issue is that biotherapeutics
require a significant amount of effort
to be committed to their purification
process and
frequently on the removal of impurities
from their product
arising from the complex feedstocks
multiple chromatographic steps are
therefore used
but in more and more cases mixed mode
chromatography
and in particular affinity
chromatography is being more frequently
used
for these purposes and
unless there's an off-the-shelf affinity
product
which for specific novel therapeutics is
unlikely
the use of affinity chromatography
requires the development
of novel ligands and absorbance specific
to the target
austria bias operations is the only
bioseparations company
to offer ligand discovery and adsorbent
development services
in combination with delivering a
large-scale manufacture of
chromatography absorbance
and production of pre-packed
chromatography columns
to gmp standards in this presentation
i will cover the strategies we take and
describe
a recent case study whereby we've
supported a customer
from ligand discovery through the
development of an absorbent
delivered in a pre-packed column format
ready for them to use
in manufacture
to support our clients and customers
with delivering their requirements
we have a dedicated program or roadmap
of work and processes the process
consists of three discrete phases and
i will go into each detail sorry i will
go into detail
on each of these phases later on at the
start of the project
using computational chemistry a number
of suitable ligands are identified
then in phase two an absorbent is
selected
and developed in parallel alongside the
identification of suitable conditions
and operational parameters this
culminates
in pinpointing a final adsorbent and
process
which is ready for phase three this
is where the absorbent is transferred to
manufacturing
accompanied with a full regulatory
support package
and thus supplying a custom adsorbent or
if required
a pre-pack column to enable the customer
to deliver
the first phase is to identify ligand
candidates
specific to the target and successive
screening
to narrow in on the top candidates for
absorpent and processed development
so how do we decide what route to take
what we know about the target and its
interactions
help us decide which strategy to follow
for ligand discovery
if the target protein structure is known
and available
and there is a known binding site we can
use ligand docking
and virtual high throughput screening
techniques
licking ligand docking means that we
take
selected ligands from our virtual
library and virtually place them
in the binding site and evaluate the fit
of the ligand
within the binding site alternatively
if the binding site is not known we will
use the binding site determination or
blind docking to identify ligands
suitable for the target protein
this is where the virtual ligand library
is screened in silico
against the protein to identify ligands
that have an affinity for the protein
binding site
when we don't have structural
information about the protein
we can use information about known
inhibitors and search for ligands with
structural similarities
of course there are also occasions when
there is no structural information
available
or known inhibitors to the target
protein
the ligand discovery approach then is
via the systematic
high throughput screening of a selection
of libraries or
the identification of a hit through a
more discrete but diverse library
as mentioned earlier i want to describe
a case study whereby we supported
one of our customers and supplying them
with a custom affinity adsorbent
in this case study we already knew the
structure of the target protein
we were also aware that there were
several different isoforms
of the target protein which the customer
ideally wanted the ligand
which could bind to all i.e a platform
technology
the feedstock which was supplied was a
clarified cell culture supernatant
containing the target isoforms but at
low concentrations
this added an extra layer of complexity
regarding the ligand discovery strategy
the following path was selected
as the target protein structure was
known and available
however the ligand binding site was not
a ligand binding site had to be
determined followed by docking studies
using computational chemistry
as we wanted a ligand that could be used
for multiple isoforms
of the target protein or proteins we
started by determining
common clefts accessible to the ligands
the surface of the protein was scanned
for possible ligand binding sites
and we used docking studies to dock the
ligand's ligand structures
to the possible binding sites as well
has determined the binding energy
overall the more negative the more
favorable however
a balance is needed to be struck whereby
we obtained
a good fit for binding ie selectivity
but not too tight as to not be able to
recover
the target material using conventional
illusion conditions
from these studies we selected a number
of possible candidates
however we needed to consider many
factors
ligand orientation is one as well as
certain restrictive factors
which can include cost ligand
availability
ligand toxicity as well as physical and
chemical restrictions
such as site accessibility and
the spacer arm which attaches the ligand
to the absorbent
the restrictive factors such as the
spacer arm
could have both a positive or negative
influence
on the binding if the spacer arm is too
hydrophobic
there could be repulsive forces which
could detrimentally affect the binding
or conversely certain charge groups or
the length of the spacer arm
may actually aid in the ligand docking
based on selective structures from the
virtual screening
we designed a library of triesine based
compounds
the library explored the chemical space
around
the selected structures it is useful to
constrain
the library so as to focus the screening
efforts
on this slide we have depicted the same
binding site
but two different candidates with
different structures
it is worth noting that the positioning
or orientation of the ligand
within the binding site is important to
allow the spacer arm to be attached
this is indicated with the circle
in both cases the ligands have an
nh3 group to couple onto the spacer arm
in
an acceptable position it is worth
highlighting of course
that in some cases the protein structure
is not known
in these cases work can be done by
initially exploring
a wider chemical space than narrowing
down the focus
as the results are generated this is
more
of an iterative approach a lot of time
is spent during this phase
to ensure that the right targets are
selected for generating
suitable libraries
this approach allows for the synthesis
of combinatorial libraries
which are ideal for identifying ligands
with mixed modes of action
the libraries generated are with
chrysine based
ligands which is the basis of most of
our ligands
trisene ligands are ligands which are
small
chemical constructs developed on a core
triazine ring
attached via a spacer arm onto an
agarose or other support
the ligand the ligand is built up by
activating the dichlorotriazine
then coupling a primary amine to the
trisene core
and creating an intermediate the
monochlorotriazine intermediate
is then further substituted to a final
two-dimensional ligand
astria standardly creates an 8x8 array
library
of subtly different ligands this
building
of ligand libraries using a wide range
of different chemical compounds
allows for the creation of an extensive
library
incorporating a wide variety of
properties
which are costly stable
the libraries generated are pure plates
which are comprised of 64 discrete
packed
micro columns with top and bottom frits
and reservoirs above
these columns will drain freely under
gravity so
automated liquid handling systems are
not required
only a multi-channel pipette
these pureplate libraries allow us to
perform
the screening like using a standard
column
allowing for equilibration sample
application
wash steps elution and cip steps
the fractions of interest are collected
by drainage into deep well collection
plates
which can be analyzed using discrete
analytical tools
such as sds page or by a variety of
plate-based assays
to measure the amount of target protein
or impurities in each fraction
this allows for a variety of factors to
be identified
for the suitable ligand which binds to
the target
once the screening is complete the
fraction samples test
the fraction samples are tested using a
range of assays
the data can then be presented as a heat
map
such like here this heat map can be
built up
based on predetermined criteria such as
binding recovery purity ease evolution
or others from these criteria
the best adsorbents are selected a heap
map
can have a nominal scoring of one to
five
when the factors based on factors which
don't have a clear defined value
assigned
such as ease of evolution or there could
be
a percentage value out of a hundred
whereby the higher the value the better
in this case the poor performing ligands
are
colored in blue and the best performing
ligands are colored in red
from the screening we select one or more
absorbance
for further development or we decide
design a new library based on these
results and repeat the process
in this case as there were several
high-performing candidates
additional scrutiny was applied to the
results to identify the top candidates
in order to proceed to the absorbent
development
once the first phase is complete and one
or more usually up to six adsorbents
depending on what was identified during
ligand discovery
and these candidates have been
identified the next phase begins
absorbent development and process
development
the absorbent development can be
effectively divided into two parts
the chemistry development and the
downstream processing
the chemistry development focuses on
many aspects
including the optimization of the space
rom
the length and how the how hydrophobic
or how hydrophilic it needs to be
as mentioned earlier the ligand density
investing investigating a range of
ligand density absorbance
to explore selectivity and capacity
ligand attachment chemistry the base
matrix selection
i previously mentioned that we couple
the ligand to purebead
which is our near monodispersed
agarose-based matrix material
however other base matrices or even
other supports
can be investigated rational
optimization
of the ligand and absorbance synthesis
for improving cost effectiveness
and process robustness is also carried
out and
the list continues for the chemistry
development
the other part is the downstream
processing this focuses
on the development of a suitable wash
elution
regeneration and cip conditions as well
as testing the performance
of the absorbance under the standard
process conditions
the downstream processing will perform
all the verification work
in relation to the work which was
carried out throughout the chemistry
development
for the ligand and absorbent synthesis
the absorbent development uses scaled-up
synthesis
of the ligands which are packed into a
variety of larger columns
and are tested for performance there are
a key
there are a range of key factors at this
stage including as said
binding capacity selectivity elution
conditions
total protein binding impurity profiles
and recoveries
cip regimes are also investigated to
ensure that the adsorbent is stable
and reusable in this case
study sorry the um the example here
is after the optimization and the
development
on the on the right hand side is the sds
page of the ligand density optimization
we identified that a lower ligand
density was preferable
not only to improve the purity but also
to ensure good recovery
it's worth noting that although this
ligand showed
high selectivity for the target protein
certain charge groups present on the
ligand
did cause some minor non-target binding
which was accentuated
with the higher ligand densities
sometimes there is
a trade-off between purity and capacity
it's worth noting on the left where we
see the material
in the load and the final target in the
illusion
we were achieved 14 grams per liter
binding
with a 96 purity and a 98
recovery after the development and
optimization
once the absorbent has been fully
developed three
verification batches are produced
usually
at the one liter scale and are evaluated
for performance
and consistency within the limits of the
process
the process samples in the case in this
case study
were run on an sds page and compared
between the three batches demonstrating
high comparability
and illusion fractions with high purity
across the single step
once the adsorbent development is
complete the absorbent is ready for tech
transfer
into production at our manufacturing
facility on the island
during tech transfer all the documents
and reports required
are transferred to our manufacturing
site via our dedicated tt team
a single batch of adsorbent is produced
at the same
or larger scale than the verification
batches
the dt batch is fully evaluated and
assessed for comparability
to that of the verification batches for
the case study
an sds page of the tech transfer batch
was performed
and demonstrated comparability to the
verification batches
with a strong main target band visible
once the tech transfer batch has been
fully evaluated
manufacturer will commence creating at
least three
validation batches
during tech transfer and at the start of
manufacture
the equipment requirements and user
requirement specifications are evaluated
the incoming raw materials in process
assays
and final product assays for the product
are assessed for their suitability
and validated ligand and adsorbent
synthesis methods are validated
and all required standard operating
procedures and badge manufacturing
records
are established validation of the
adsorbent synthesis
is usually performed with the
manufacture of a minimum
of three batches usually at a larger
scale to that of the tt batch
demonstrating comparability and quality
the custom adsorbent is now a fully
validated and supported product
and can be supplied to the customer
however to fully support and enable the
customer
estrella also offers a column packing
service
if this is desired a packing development
program is initiated
to fully understand the packing
properties of the absorbent
and define all the parameters required
to produce
a uniform and robust packing process
this method follows the same route once
again
back through tech transfer and into
manufacture
along with our external testing
including transportation testing
we ensure that we can deliver a
plug-and-play play product
to the customer estrella also provide
smaller lab scale columns to perform
screening and process development
with their custom adsorbent if selected
or
one of a range of off-the-shelf products
for the case study discussed in this
presentation
we provided the customer with multiple
batches of pre-packed
evolved d seven and ten centimeter
diameter
gmp ready columns which are a perfect
fit for their requirements
we support our customers through each
stage from ligand discovery
to adsorbent and process development
once
a suitable candidate has been identified
and optimized
we undertake the tech transfer of a
robust process
for either adsorbent or column packing
services
we also provide a range of columns from
lab to process scale
through our technology people and our
processes
estrella has the capability to provide a
product or service which fits your needs
if anyone wants to find out more please
visit our website
at www.australiabuyseparations.com
thank you for your time and attention if
you have any questions regarding this
presentation
or any of our products or services
please please feel free to stop by our
booth or email sales at
australiahyphenbio.com